on Saturday night Samantha be hosted the
much-ballyhooed not the White House
Correspondents Dinner the general was
retitled of course because President
Trump wasn't enough of a rube to subject
himself to three hours of Barb's and
put-downs by leftist who didn't vote for
him and see him as a joke and sustained
his voters at the dinner be trotted out
of the white pantsuit looking like
Kristin Chenoweth playing Hillary
Clinton in an alternative reality
version of the 2016 election your job
has never been harder she gushed to the
assembled members of the self-pleasuring
press you expose injustice against the
weak you continue to fact-check the
president's as if he might someday get
embarrassed tonight is for you
shortly after this ode to the bravery of
journalists who maintained total silence
for eight years of President Barack
Obama's lies on Iran and healthcare his
Department of Justice targeting the
Associated Press and Fox News he
appeared on CNN with Jake Tapper there
she explained of her nearly unwatchable
mess of a show full frontal quote I do
the show for me and for people like me
and I don't care how the rest of the
world sees it frankly we birth it and
then the word of the world receives it
however they want to receive it during
the entirety of this statement a smug
grin was plastered across her face here
is a basic rule of thumb in order to be
smug you generally have to be unaware of
your smugness be fits the bill so did
the members of the White House press
corps there's plenty of questions and
there are plenty of questions about
president Trump's administration from
his shifting promises to his knee-jerk
reversals from his policy vagaries to
his staff and chaos but instead of
approaching the American people as
potential friends to be convinced smug
leftists treat them as ignoramuses
there's no sincerity involved every
critique of Trump supporters lumps them
all together and then treats them as
dumb and stuck to the bottom of the shoe
of the Republic
Samantha being company had the
unmistakable air of the bullies from
every high school and college comedy
preening self-obsessed rich kids who
sneer at the losers who inhabit the
hallways and plan pool parties and taunt
the poor kids you can't support anything
better than a beat-up Enzo the
journalist Hollywood clique is like Greg
Maher maillard from Animal House Rob
from Breaking Away Regina George for
Mean Girls their smug their liberal and
that's what drives Trump support Trump
knows this that's why he skipped the
Correspondents Dinner and instead once
Pennsylvania where he held a rally
hilariously declaring quote a large
group of Hollywood actors in Washington
media are consoling each other in a
hotel ballroom in our nation's capital
right now it was the best moment for
Trump since his speech to a joint
session of Congress Trump may not be
popular among the cool kids but he's
cool enough among them to win supporters
in the swing states if the cool kids
don't cut it out they'll get eight years
to mock him and
smug in their self assurance that they
know what the American people want
better than the American people do I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
already so James Comey is on the hill
again this guy just won't go away the
FBI director is back on the hill now
answering questions about the election
cycle Hillary Clinton is back to the
2016 election cycle will never end so if
you loved it congratulations
it's 2017 the revenge will get to all of
that in just a second but first I want
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
legacy box comm so one of the big things
that I talk about all the time is
preserving your memories obviously as
you get older those memories go into a
box they go in the garage and there's
nothing much that you can do with them
anymore unless you go to legacy box.com
well you did you take all those old
photos you take all of that old video
all those old films and stuff that your
grandma left you and you put it in a box
and you send it to legacy box and they
send you back everything on a DVD or a
thumb drive so that you can use it and
watch it and share it and relive it it's
a fantastic service is something I think
is deeply important because as those
memories disappear you're losing a part
of yourself legacy box prevents that
from happening so instead of your home
movies being stacked up in a closet
similar now you can actually look at
them anytime you want because they're
easy and convenient you don't have to
schlep boxes of crap out of your house
if there's a fire legacy voxcom takes
cares they take care of everything
they provide updates at every step of
the process that's why 250,000 families
have used them so right now if you go to
legacy box comm /ban you get a 40%
discount on your order legacy box comm
slash been fantastic service again send
all of your stuff to them they send it
back on tape they put a barcode on every
piece of material that you send to them
so you can track where it is in the
process just a great company legacy box
comm slash Ben go ahead check it out 40%
discount on your order okay so the big
news today is that James Comey is on the
hill now as the precursor to this I
think we have to talk about Hillary
Clinton's reappearance on the public
scene so Hillary is back and this is a
great thing for Republicans because
particularly it's great for Trump I'm
not sure it's so great for Republicans
as much as it's great for Trump the
reason I say it's great for Trump is
because the ledge Trump does in office
the more important it is to talk about
how terrible Hillary Clinton is because
again you need to show you need to throw
Trump and relief if your basis for Trump
doing
a job as he's not Hillary then Hillary
needs to be ever-present in our mind we
need to constantly remember how terrible
Hillary is when we think oh god at least
it's not Hillary Clinton Trump must be
doing a fantastic job so that's why
Hillary being part of the public scene
is really really good for Trump so
Hillary came back yesterday and she was
doing a media appearance with Christiane
Amanpour who's just unwatchable and
unlistenable and in this media in this
media appearance she said that she takes
full responsibility and then proceeds to
blame everybody up to it including Jim
James Comey
the head of the FBI did we make mistakes
of course we did did I make mistakes oh
my gosh yes you know you'll read my
confession and my my request for
absolution but the reason why I believe
we lost were the intervening events in
the last 10 days okay so basically I
take full responsibility except I take
none of the responsibility none of it
was my fault now was it her fault yes
the whole thing is revolved the entire
email controversy is her fault if she
weren't a paranoid nutso she wouldn't
have stuck all this classified
information on an email server that was
that was private and not under
government auspices and might have been
hacked and she certainly would not have
allowed Huma Abedin - apparently send
classified information to her husband's
computer Huma Abedin of course was her
assistant and she was sending emails to
the computer of Anthony Weiner who may
Abaddon's husband Anthony Weiner of
course is a is a alleged child
pornographer or at least looking at
child pornography or young teenagers
he's a really sick guy who has a bunch
of problems does Anthony Weiner and his
computer was apparently filled with
classified material and messages from
Hillary Clinton including emails that
Hillary Clinton had deleted before
turning them over to the appropriate
intelligence authorities so as you
recall on October 28th just a few days
before the election 11 days before the
election James Comey sends an email
sends a letter to the members of
Congress updating them on the status of
the investigation if you recall all the
way back to July in July he says we've
done a full investigation of Hillary's
email server and while she's a criminal
she is not a criminal and we should not
prosecute her that was basically Kobe's
announcement back in July now it comes
to 11 days before the election and James
Comey sends a letter to Congress telling
them we haven't reopened the email
investigation per se but we have new in
formation in the email investigation and
anthony Weiner's computer is filled
chock full to the top with a bunch of
Hillary Clinton emails we haven't had
time to go through it yet now this was
pretty controversial because just a few
days later he comes down he says we went
through all of it nothing there of
importance so Democrats I think not
wrongly are very missed by this they say
okay why are you updating Congress if
you haven't even checked it out you
don't know if it's real yet and then
five days six days seven days later you
come out and you say oh by the way I'm
glad I updated you eight days ago but it
turns out that none of it actually
mattered so back to my original
statement nothing bad happened here if
you were a Democrat you'd be mad too if
you're Republican obviously you're happy
because of course it had an impact on
Trump getting elected it's still
Hillary's fault she shouldn't have
engaged in all sorts of nefarious
activity here she should have been more
careful with classified information
she shouldn't have planned to have a
server and then put classified material
on it which is a purposeful exposure of
America to two foreign intelligence
services she should never have done any
of those things so tillery's fault but
did commis letter have an impact I think
would be hard to argue commis letter
didn't have an impact you see the polls
she dropped from outside the margin of
error to inside the margin of error in
the last few days of the election cycle
hard to tell how much of that would have
happened normally but it's hard to
imagine that the biggest story in
America didn't have any impact on her
electability and then in case James
Comey is testifying before Congress and
Dianne Feinstein senator from California
she of the nightly sighs she decides
that she's going to ask him about why he
sent that famous October 28th letter and
here's James commis answer the
investigative team that had finished the
investigation in July focused on
secretary Clinton's emails asked to meet
with me so I met with them that morning
late morning in my conference room and
they laid out for me what they could see
from the metadata on this fella Anthony
Weiner's laptop that had been seized in
an unrelated case what they could see
from the metadata was that there were
thousands of secretary Clinton's emails
on that device including what they
thought might be the missing emails from
her first three months of Secretary of
State we never found any emails from her
first three months she was using a
Verizon blackberry then and that's
obviously very important because if
there was evidence that she was acting
with bad intent that's where it would be
in the first a four
there look and I just finished my answer
senator and so the K minutes that we can
see thousands of emails from the Clinton
email domain including many many many
from the Verizon Clinton domain
blackberry domain they said we think we
got to get a search warrant to go get
these and the Department of Justice
agreed we had to go get a search warrant
so i agreed i authorized the Masika
search warrant and then i faced a choice
and i'd live my entire career by the
tradition if you can possibly avoid it
you avoid any action the run-up to an
election that might have an impact
whether it's a dog catcher election or
President of the United States but i sat
there that morning and I could not see a
door labeled no action here I could see
two doors and they were both actions one
was labeled speak the other was labeled
concealed because here's how I thought
about I'm not trying to talk you into
this but I want you to know my thinking
having repeatedly told this Congress we
are done and there's nothing there
there's no case there there's no case
there to restart in a hugely significant
way potentially finding the emails that
would reflect on her intent from the
beginning and not speak about it would
require an act of concealment in my view
and so I stared at speak in conceal
speak would be really bad there's an
election in eleven days lordy that would
be really bad concealing in my view
would be catastrophic not just to the
FBI but well beyond and honestly as
between really bad and catastrophic I
said to my team were got to walk into
the world are really bad I've got to
tell Congress that we're restarting this
not in some frivolous way in a hugely
significant way and the team also told
me we cannot finish this work before the
election and then they worked night
after night after night and they found
thousands of new emails they found
classified information on Anthony Weiner
somehow her emails are being forwarded
to Anthony Weiner including classified
information by her assistant Huma Abedin
and so they found thousands of new
emails and then called me the Saturday
night before the election and said
thanks to the wizardry of our technology
we've only had to personally read six
thousand we think we can finish tomorrow
morning Sunday and so I met with them
and they said we found a lot of new
stuff we did not find anything that
changes our view
of her intent so we're in the same place
we were in July
it hasn't changed our view and I asked
them lots of questions and I said okay
if that's where you are then I also have
to tell Congress that we're done look
this is a terrible
it makes me mildly nauseous to think
that we might have had some impact on
the election but honestly it wouldn't
change the decision everybody who
disagrees with me has to come back to
October 28th of me and stare at this and
tell me what you would do would you
speak or would you conceal so he can
stop it here so I'm about to say
something deeply unpopular James Comey
is totally utterly completely full of
crap okay he's totally full of crap I
know that people on the right Seamus is
super convincing
this is his logic this is why he did it
he's an honest man okay James Comey is
totally full of crap he's full of crap
in July he was full of crap in October
and he's full of crap now I'll explain
why okay beginning in July he was full
of crap because he never should have
announced all the reasons to indict
Hillary Clinton and then made up his own
legal standard and he did you talked
about at the time he literally made up
his own legal standard there is no
standard of intent in the law with
regard to concealment and hiding and
redirection of classified material there
is no intent requirement he made up that
standard out of whole cloth to exonerate
Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump I mean
this is so bizarre now because this is
the world we live in
Trump tweeted that yesterday he tweeted
yesterday that James Comey gave Hillary
a free pass okay well you reappointed
him to head of the FBI dude like you
said you weren't going to fire him
that's kind of weird but in July he was
totally full of crap then because he set
this wrong legal standard he then goes
forward to October and now it turns out
that there's all sorts of new material
so he has two choices he can shut the
hell up
until all the information isn't
available to him until he completes the
investigation without regard for
politics or he can announce it to make
up for his boo-boo ready to make up call
July was a boo-boo and now he's got a
make up call in October here's the make
up call Republicans have a field day and
he sends out this letter and he openly
said this at the time like this new
logic they saying where he's saying well
you know I really felt the obligation to
saying if they say something because it
was either speak or conceal and I didn't
want to politicize this thing he says
that he at one point in this testimony
he actually says that somebody in his
office said you know you're gonna get
Trump elected if you do this and he said
well I can't think about things like
that well clearly he was thinking about
things like that back in July and he was
thinking like that about things like
that in October because litter
only five seconds later he says in that
same testimony he says we expedited the
review well if you aren't worried about
the plot of the politics of the
situation while you expediting the
review right if all you're worried about
is the truth coming out in good time
then number one why are you announcing
preliminary findings before you've even
done the research and two why aren't you
waiting until all the research is done
and three why are you expediting the
research so that it gets done before the
election cycle and four why are you
sending this letter that you sent to the
FBI the same day that you sent the
letter to Congress quote of course we
don't ordinarily tell Congress about
ongoing investigations but here I feel
an obligation to do so given that I
testified repeatedly in recent months
that our investigation was completed I
also think it would be misleading to the
American people will Rinat to supplement
the record at the same time however
given we don't know the significance of
this newly discovered collection of
emails I don't want to create a
misleading impression in trying to
strike that balance in a brief letter
and in the middle of an election season
there a significant risk of being
misunderstood but I wanted you to hear
directly from me about it yes there was
politics here but the only politics that
mattered to James call me was not the
politics of Trump versus Clinton the
only politics that mattered to James
Comey was preserving his patina of
legitimacy at the FBI and creating this
perception that the FBI was above
politics when in fact by doing all of
this embroiled the FBI in more and more
and more politics that's what actually
happened here okay that's what actually
happened here with James Comey James
Comey hedged his bets so he could keep
his job he started in July exonerating
Hillary where she should not have been
exonerated then to hedge his bets in
October he brought forward this
information and then he killed his own
information like eight days later after
this whole thing went down and that's
the honest take on James coming well
you're gonna hear today from the
partisans on both side left is going to
say James Comey is totally evil and
wanted Trump to win and on the right
you're going to hear James Comey is
wonderful he's a saint of course he had
to reveal this information here is the
basic truth
it's Hillary's fault she lost its James
commis fault that we all know about any
of this stuff in the first place because
James Comey did not do the first thing
FBI directors are told to do shut your
mouth until you have all the information
okay and here's the reality of the
situation would I prefer that the
information came out and Hillary did not
get elected of course of course is James
Comey simultaneously full of crap
absolutely James Comey is simultaneously
full of crap
okay now I want to talk
I want to say thank you to our
advertisers over at Raptor and then I
want to talk a little bit more about
Hillary's grand return so tracker comm
the tracker comm ta are tra wrapper tra
CK are calm noe the tracker comm a use
promo code Benin here's what the tracker
does if you lose your stuff you lose
your phone if you lose your keys if you
lose your wallet you stick this coin
sized device on your phone on your keys
on your wallet and it allows you to find
those things you use your cell phone to
locate your keys you you if it rings
basically from your cell phone to your
keys and to your wallet and that ensures
that you never lose these things again
if you're one not to lose your phone
then you can actually use your keys as a
reverse tracking device you take the
device and then you can actually reverse
it back to your phone and it'll ring
through so how often do you lose your
phone and your phone is on silent and
you can't find it the tracker allows you
to actually override the no ring device
it allows you override this it's been a
godsend for me I'm constantly guy
running out the door and looking for
wallet phone keys and losing one of them
and this makes it possible the tracker
makes it possible for that not to happen
for me I don't have to spend 15 minutes
looking for my stuff anymore the tracker
calm and use promo code Ben you get a
free tracker Bravo with any purchase so
you never have to worry about losing
that stuff ever again find its location
with a tap of button the tracker comm
promo code Ben it's a device that my
wife uses as I've said before it saved
our marriage because there's nothing
that noise both of us more than when we
lose our objects and then we have to
bother the spouse about it the tracker
comm promo code been in a free tracker
Bravo with any purchase
okay so Hillary Clinton can't accept the
fact that James Comey screwed things up
but she really can't accept the fact
that she's the one who screwed things up
right she can't deal with the fact that
she's the one who blew it
and so she is still not taking
responsibility instead she's claiming
that it's because of Americans being
sexist or some such nonsense
were you a victim of misogyny and why do
you think you lost the majority of the
white female vote the security mom the
people who want to be projected from the
time
of challenges you're talking about right
now right well you know that the books
coming out in the fall have you just to
give you a tiny little preview yes I do
think it played a role I think other
things did as well every day that goes
by we learn more about some of the
unprecedented interference including
from a foreign power whose leader is not
a member of my fan club and so I think
it is it is real it is very much a part
of the landscape
politically okay so it's obviously
because we don't like women now this
ignores the fact I do love this is where
my favorite things the election cycle
somebody actually took the Clinton Trump
debate and they reversed the sexist they
had a woman read Trump's comments and
then a man read Hillary's comments and
turns out people liked Hillary even less
when she was a man so so the idea that
people just didn't vote for her because
she's a woman is of course crap but she
now declares herself part of the
resistance she's going to help stop
Donald Trump
I spent decades learning about what it
would take to move our country forward
including people who you know clearly
didn't vote for me to try to make sure
that we dealt with a lot of these hard
issues that are right around the corner
like robotics and artificial
intelligence and things that are really
going to be up ending the economy for
the vast majority of Americans to say
nothing of the rest of the world so you
know I'm now back to being an activist
citizen and part of the resistance
and everybody yeah okay the worst thing
that could happen to the resistance is
Hillary Clinton be a part of it I mean
she she does have the resistance of a
particularly viral strain virulent
strain of syphilis but aside from that
there's nothing going on that would
would remotely suggest that she is going
to help out the resistance in any way
she's trying to hijack a youth movement
that she's just incapable of hijacking
and even people on her left are saying
that she's totally full of it but to
talk about that we're going to have to
go over to Daley wire.com you're going
to have to become a subscriber $8 a
month get two subscriptions at Daley
wired.com plus if you want an annual
subscription you get a free copy of the
arroyo fictional DVD two movie sent on
the southern border action Western all
about ranchers trying to defend their
land from drug cartels trying to use it
as a thoroughfare at the arroyo Jeremy
boring the Arroyo I'll go check it out
by getting an annual subscription plus
if you get a subscription right now
annual or otherwise then you can be part
of the mailbag tomorrow and we will do a
live mailbag tomorrow we'll take your
questions live on air which of course
makes your life markedly better in every
possible way daily wire.com or if you
just want to listen at iTunes or
SoundCloud
we always appreciate if you subscribe
over there and make sure that you leave
us a review we always appreciate that as
well we are the largest conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
you